in the latest episode of the Mandalorian
there's a scene that just doesn't make
sense or perhaps I'm an uneducated Star
Wars fan so there's a scene towards the
end of an episode where the armor toes
broke Katana to remove her helmet and
explains to her that she's able to walk
both ways meaning she can either keep
her helmet on or she can keep it off now
what in the double standards has
happened here because armor made a whole
fuss about Amanda Lauren danger and
becoming an apostate and making a whole
big ordeal that he must be redeemed he
must go to Living Waters of man in the
way if not his exiled and he's not
welcomed in this clan and now to Boca
Town she's like yeah no problem you can
keep your helmet off that's all good
you're welcome here but yet din John
can't do the same now it seems like the
armor is just mythical whipped and
that's why she's more leaning towards
Barry Katan because she has seen the
mythosaur so she's thinking she can
reunite all of the Clans and stuff like
that but my opinion it still doesn't
make sense while denjari can't walk both
ways but yet boo Katan can unless if
I've misinterpreted this scene entirely
so let me know what you guys think in
the comment section below do you agree
with me or do disagree with me but if
you're new to the Channel please
consider subscribing and like the video
If you enjoyed thanks for watching guys